our next speaker is lisa
taraneko and i hope i didn't trash your
name too bad lisa she earned a master's
in genomics and bioinformatics at
siberian federal university
so she is currently a phd student in
plant site physiology her phd thesis is
about plant genomics epigenetics and
genome annotation of oil palm
wow she's interested in all kinds of
areas loves working on mammals studying
genomics and transcriptonomics
another fascinating type of omics data
is metagenomics and we have been hearing
about all the microbiome a lot it's a
role in health disease therapy and even
prevention and now let's
invite lisa from the tauber
bioinformatics research center to speak
about
metagenomics data analysis and how it
can be performed in the t bio info
platform so welcome lisa we really are
looking forward to hearing about your
area of interest the floor is yours
thank you for having me uh can you see
my screen well
yep
okay
um yeah my name is lisa very i'm very
happy to be here and i'll be speaking
about chime um it is a tool
that we use to analyze metagenomics data
and metagenomics is really about
microbial communities we want to learn
the composition of them and compare them
between each other
metagenomics is used in a variety of
areas in agriculture health care
biotechnology where everywhere but this
topic will be mostly about technical
side of analysis on the platform not the
biological one
so
on our platform
there is a possibility to
sorry
there is a possibility to use two types
of data
upload data
there is a manual upload when you have
all the files downloaded on your
laptop or computer
and ncbi upload so the set of files
needed for each is a bit different
in each case you need metadata where you
have the groupings of your interest
but for manual upload you also have to
have fastq files with your reads and
in case it is multiplex data you also
need barcodes
so
maybe you're already familiar with the
concept of multiplex data it's when in
one run we have several samples and
they're differentiated by the barcodes
so
when this file is in chime it needs
these barcodes to
separate the samples again
and in ncbi we only need metadata and
this metadata is used to download all
the all the fastq files that we need
so on the
upload panel you have to pick your type
of upload manual or ncbi and you also
have to pick if you have single or
paired and reads
and select the file type if it's manual
upload
for in cbi upload this is a
typical
metadata file and the critical column
here is the first one which has the sra
ids and they will be used to download
all the data you need
where to find this file so you have to
search the sra archive and look for the
study that interests you and there will
be this metadata button
that will start the download of the
metadata file just be careful because
sometimes it downloads the file uh with
commas as separators but we only
we can only accept tab separated files
so sometimes this file needs a bit of
correcting before running the pipeline
so when the upload is done either
manually or
with the help of ncbi we can start
building our
graph
and um chime is separated into five
subsections and we start with
pre-processing
so first we import data
data to chime then with filters samples
we can filter out samples that are too
few in the
number of reads
and then we want to see the quality
control um the quality of our reads
uh then
moving on to processing out use that's
oppression operational taxonomic units
and here we have two algorithms the
noise in algorithm data ii and the blue
and what they do they create the um well
they identify the operational taxonomic
units and they calculate the abundance
in each sample and with this table we
can proceed to taxonomy
where we classify our otus with
existing database in this case it's
silva database for 16s rna
where you have to pick your region of
the region that was used for sequencing
in our case it was
variable region 4.
and you can alter your classification
well resulting
data if you want
and then we can move on to metrics
where core metrics calculates all the
alpha and
beta diversity indexes
and then we can
visualize alpha diversity with box plots
and for beta diversity
we will need to pick a column for
testing beta diversity and here i want
to
remind what beta diversity is about
because for alpha diversity this is
measures different measures that study
the community within itself
but beta diversity uh compares the
communities between each other
so here we
have to pick
some
some column that
has grouping of samples that in is we're
interested in
in my case it was the body side that was
the sample was taken from
and after beta diversity uh
we also can use interactive
visualization and there we also have to
pick two columns to visualize in my case
i picked bodyside and antibiotic usage
so
when we are ready with our table and uh
oh sorry graph and we ran this pipeline
and it's finished successfully
you will see this external dashboard um
here but actually let me try and go to
the
browser
okay it's here
so this is the pipeline that
successfully finished and i want to
check my results with the dashboard
so let's go here
you can see that in the dashboard
there are three areas of data
there's big bar plots
some
nmds and alpha diversity box plots
and apart from this dashboard tab we
also have a table tab
this is the table that all our plots are
based on
and you can have your otu
ids
and all the counts here for each sample
this is rarefied table meaning that if
you sum up all the abundances for each
sample they will be the same
you can download this data and it will
open you the raw
look of this file you can just copy it
and paste it into text document
you can also download metadata or
taxonomy where for taxonomy it's the
same
logic you have your otu id and all the
taxonomic units
so um
uh and also you can look
what this otu is associated with what
taxonomic
what text it is associated with here we
have family but again you can look at
different
levels
so back to bash dashboard
this rarefied table is used to
plot these bar plots
um let me make it a bit bigger
um these bar plots that have samples and
relative abundance and you can play with
this graph the way you want you can
again pick the uh different taxonomic
levels you can pick different coloring
to your liking oh this is not very good
okay let's stick to this
you can download a csv for of this
table or anything
and if you're interested for example
this sample
this uh what tax it is and what exactly
the abundance
is for this sample for this texan
next is nmds
this is
something like a principle component
analysis or principle coordinate
analysis also a dimensional reduction
technique that tries to show the
pairwise dissimilarities between the
samples
here it's
also
colors are controlled by these columns
in your metadata
and if i want
not two but only one i can pick
the same color here and it will be like
one group
um also if we point at it
it will show
what is the symbol and the color and
coordinates in this three-dimensional
space and the sample
name
and also the alpha diversity box plot
here it all
only shows observed otus
and you can also group it by
any column from your metadata
and for example in body side
um we have 71 observed o2s in gut and
779 165
observed otus in
palms a lot more than in the gut
but this is the dashboard
but actually chime creates a bit more
information than that
and if you want to
look into beta diversity
or more indexes from alpha diversity you
can go to download pipeline
output files and here you will see
a zip folder for each job that finished
successfully and i'm interested in alpha
diversity
and in beta diversity for example
so
um
let me go back to my presentation sorry
about it
okay we
already finished this
yeah
so
here you have to um get familiar with
how actually chime operates it has two
types of data it has q-z-a files and
q-z-v files and both are normally
unreadable to us
with our regular tools
qset a
has all the tables in it and so we
modify it into txt tables for you to
look at but q.v files are visualization
files and they are specifically designed
to be viewed on the online browser of
chime
and it looks like this and you just take
the file with
qzv at the end and drag it here drop it
and for example let's look at
beta diversity uh here uh break curtis
distance is used to calculate the
distance matrix for the samples and we
colored them the same way
with body side we can see
nice differentiation between the body
sides
but
both palms are together which is also
makes sense
another
distance metric jacquard is used here
and they both are
visualized in the emperor plot which is
principle coordinate analysis
algorithm
and we have two more um
two more distance metrics uh
metrics that are used by chime it's
weighted unit fractional and unweighted
um
then if we move on to alpha diversity
visualization we can
check out a bit more of the indices that
there are for example faith index that
shows us the evenness and richness of
the community but it takes into
accordance the philogenetic relationship
between our otus and here
um we again see that left ball and right
palm are really um
rich
compared to guts
uh but we actually can kinda see it in
our bar plot we can see that our gut
samples which are these
they are
mostly
comprised of three
um taxa
and for example these are palms we can
see that there are a lot more different
bacteria are there
so um apart from box plots chime also
calculates statistics
all groups and pairwise statistics
and
for example uh here's gut uh versus our
three other tissues
and we can see that there is significant
difference with palms but it's not
significantly different from tongue
which also makes sense
and other metrics are the evenness which
shows how
even
each oto is present in the sample
and
just remembering the boxed foot i showed
you uh the palms are
a lot more evenly present um
than the gut where we have only three
like three bacteria there
and shannon index which also shows
evenness and richness
so
thank you very much for your
time and for having me here um i'm ready
for questions
all right i am here i just have to
switch toys to help you out here we do
have a couple questions and thank you
for all that lisa that was uh
fascinating so here's the first question
how has metagenomic data analysis been
used in cancer research
i'm not sure about cancer research just
since i'm really never did it in cancer
research
but i believe that
um
just meta-dynamics in general for human
is used excessively to understand some
under um
some
physiological problems
that cannot be unders
that cannot be explained by
other techniques for example there are
some diseases
that
genetically we kind of understand but
still the um
like the behavior of our
gastrin uh gi tract is cannot be only
explained by the genetics that's when
a metagenomics step in and try to
analyze the microbiome in our gut and
explain this behavior
but in cancer i really want to know
how it's used there
okay sorry about that it wasn't an
attempt to throw you off um just
hopefully find an answer there but thank
you yeah what are major challenges faced
during analyzing metagenomic data
well we rely heavily on the database to
classify our otus so i think this is oh
this is one of the
hardest parts because
most of the databases they don't have
ideal taxonomic
information now
sometimes we end up with a
order
of the bacteria and that's the best that
we can get this is a bit troublesome
and um
also situation
there is a difficulty with understanding
where when there is a contamination
because contamination mostly is
bacterial contamination and here we
already are working with bacteria so
sometimes it gets tricky
but i think that classification is kind
of the hardest part in metagenomics
okay thank you
how about this one how can one
transition from statistical analysis to
interpretation of metagenomic data
analysis
from statistical analysis
to interpretation of the metagenomic
data
you mean statistical analysis not a
major in statistical analysis i just how
to go from this cross cold wall is test
to understand how it's by like okay
um
well
you have to work with biologists
sometimes
because well if you really know the
subject well i guess you can interpret
it yourself but most of the time it
really needs um understanding of the
processes and what we can expect because
a lot of things
can go in a way that we do not expect
and that is wrong because sometimes
experiments go wrong and we have to
understand when we are wrong where we
are looking at something that doesn't
make any sense
so
um i would pick
a
biologist in my team
if i had
had a chance and um
right
sorry
phone a friend right yeah yeah something
like that
exactly
can microbot bile communities that you
study be modulated with bacterial phages
in a targeted way
sorry
in
micromicrobial communities that you
study be modulated with bacteriophages
in a targeted way
we
target this
yeah bacteriophages so can you
target specific taxa of
microbes
with phages
um i'm not very knowledgeable in this
area but i think yes we can
but
how would you identify such phages do
you know
well um
how we differentiate text by uh
different differences in the genomes in
this variable parts if we uh
i think that we can um
target our phages to these sequences but
i'm really not familiar with the process
how to do that
okay
how about this one what are your
thoughts on using mic using the
microbiome as a fertilizer in
agriculture
well
i think it i'm not sure because uh there
are different bacteria who well which
work in the soil and which work in the
gut i'm not sure if the same bacteria
will do the same job well
um but we definitely
use
uh
species from other animals for uh
soil so maybe there is somebody in that
okay well our apologies for putting you
on the stop and we never know what the
questions are going to come in and and
if they're all perfect for you so thank
you so much and uh we will let you go
for your afternoon thank you so much
lisa we really appreciate that yeah bye